okay so I'm recording could you just
tell me maybe what you had for breakfast
yeah nothing
I had nothing for breakfast I never eat
breakfast okay oh yeah just once a day
all right we're gonna talk about that
for sure let me just pause this optimal
at this altitude
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking and I ask
you a personal question
now it's in I'm a cybernetic organism
living tissue over metal endoskeleton
this episode is brought to you by
audible which I've used for years
I love audio books and I have to to
recommend right off the bat
number one is pressed my favorite audio
book of all time and that is the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman the only
audiobook I've wanted to immediately
listen to a second time as soon as I
finished it's amazing
you will thank me to the graveyard book
the second is vagabonding Bhairav pots
which had a huge impact on my life and
form the basis for a lot of what became
the 4-hour workweek so all you need to
do to get your free audiobook and a free
30-day trial is go to audible.com
forward slash tim and you can choose one
of those two books the graveyard book
bag bonding or more than 180,000 audio
programs so that could be a book that
could be a magazine that could be a
newspaper could be a class it's that
easy go to audible.com forward slash Tim
that's audible.com forward slash Tim and
grab a book enjoy this episode is
brought to you by a new sponsor so
listen up folks this is a good one
because have you ever wanted to be as
powerful as a mullet wearing ninja from
1980s movie or as flamboyant as big gay
al Big Al in South Park or a sleek as a
black panther in the Amazon on the hunt
well there's great news because I've
been testing this product that you wrap
around your genitals and it makes you
feel like a superhero and it is called
me undies
that's over the last two to three weeks
traveling with underwear from these guys
and they are comfy I got to tell you it
feels like a Geisha is giving your groin
a hug and it's not just for do
but if you go to meet undies calm
forward-slash Tim that's ma Eun di es
calm forward-slash Tim you can see all
of the underwear that I've been wearing
there's some pretty ridiculous ones and
I will also highlight my favorite you'll
probably be able to guess which it is
these underwear are made from micro mud
owl which is extruded from Austrian
beechwood trees in the Alps yes
fancy and it's two times softer than
cotton scientifically tested using the
kalibata method developed in Kyoto
you know those Japanese very crafty and
I will say a few things number one if
you go to me on DS comm forward slash
Tim you get to see all of the
spectacular underwear that I've been
wearing and I am a bit of an underwear
connoisseur socks fashion sense with
sweatpants not so much underwear I
understand so check them out and if you
go to my undies come forward slash Tim
you will also be able to see lots of hot
ladies wearing me undies female
underwear and that's just a lot of
goodness for both the men and the women
out there so check it out me undies
dot-com forward slash Tim I love these
underwear and I am going to be packing
tonight probably six to twelve pair to
take with me to Australia they're great
check them out me undies comm forward
slash Tim why hello lemurs and
leprechauns this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers
whether they are actors like Arnold
Schwarzenegger military strategists or
generals like Stanley McChrystal chess
prodigies like Josh Waitzkin or in this
particular case a miracle worker of
sorts in fact you could say he is a
daredevil wim HOF otherwise known as the
Iceman is a dutch world record holder
adventurer certainly daredevil and he's
nicknamed The Iceman for his ability to
withstand extreme cold he is creator of
the wim HOF method and holds more than
20 World Records he is in my mind the
outlier of outliers not because he does
so many absurd things and proves that
these Impossibles are in fact possible
but he routinely asks scientists to
scrutinize and validate these feats
that's what makes him very very unique
and very interesting for this type of
conversation what are some of his feets
well in 2007 he climb
the Death Zone the altitude on Mount
Everest which is around 7,500 meters
wearing nothing but shorts 2009 he
completed a full marathon above the
Polar Circle and Finland and
temperatures close to negative 20
degrees Celsius again dressed in nothing
but shorts
he holds the Guinness world record for
the longest ice bath which is around at
one hour 53 minutes and 12 seconds but
it's not just cold he has run full
marathons in the Namib Desert without
any water he has also had toxins
injected into himself under doctor's
supervision and demonstrated he can
effectively control his autonomic immune
response this is crazy talk these are
things that fly in the face of many
textbooks and now he is featured in
textbooks himself because he has
documented all this and it's not just a
whim specialty he is not a mutant he is
able to train others to achieve many of
these same effects and abilities in some
cases with just four days of training so
we'll dig into all this and more I love
this conversation he is a human guinea
pig of human guinea pigs certainly and
makes me feel like an amateur so without
further ado please enjoy my conversation
with wim HOF welcome to the show wim I'm
so pleased to have you great thank you
for welcoming me this way thank you very
much I have been a fan for quite a few
years because we have as we mentioned
before we started recording a mutual
friend in ray Krone eyes and he was in
my second book so I looked very closely
at cold exposure and of course you the
Iceman came up over and over again so
it's really nice to finally chat with
you it's I feel like it's been a long
time coming and also had to pass guests
or three pass guests on this podcast
Laird Hamilton and Bryan McKenzie and
also Gabby Reece
Laird's wife who are big fans of your
methods and techniques who've been
practicing so they are you you have a
lot a lot of fans out there I'm sure
listening as well and I thought we could
just start with your name I've always
loved your name is wim your full name
yes you know you I am web in does that
it doesn't have any particular meaning
or how did your parents choose that name
wait
a common name in the in Holland in the
Netherlands but I looked it up and it
says it's the protector of the people
you know any name has got some
etiological roots to it my name is the
protector of people my brother's name
who is it my twin brother is Andrey
Andrey on phone say in Andrey and drew
like Andrew he's the protector of goods
so who's better I don't know I said
especially both you need yeah it's a
protection right and you have such a
fascinating story and you have a lot of
accolades a lot of records I think more
than 20 World Records at this point it
seems uh what was the first world record
that you said the first was in Paris
just staying half hour in the immersed
in heist and 12 days later I repeated
the record time and make it to mate made
it an hour in Hollywood actually yes and
I saw one also I mean you've you've been
you spent a lot of time in ice baths and
I've largely influenced by you and a
handful of other people Tim Noakes ray
and a huge fan of ice baths and my fans
always complain about it but I've seen
you in so many containers full of ice I
saw one where it looks like there was a
lot of Chinese or Japanese in the
background what is that what has been
the most challenging cold exposure
experience that you've had whether it's
for records or anything else maybe
losing my sight while I was swimming
underneath a a ice deck of almost one
meter and I had no goggles on so a lost
side at 35 meters something like 40
yards and I lost the hole and yeah I
think it's like that [ __ ] happen it
happened over there right
that meter eyes that bear above me so
yeah that was some great experience
another one was losing my way on Mount
Everest in shorts and at like 18,000
feet in the in a blizzard in a like a
wideout so things like that happen yeah
and they are challenging but then it
throws me back to you know the depth of
my self to and which is trust and
confidence and I got what do you say to
yourself in one of those moments so if I
guess physiologically did your did your
retinas just freeze or when you were
swimming under the ice deck in a moment
like that when many people would panic I
mean did you panic if so how what was
the mental self talk when you realize
that was happening very interesting it
is the stress level at the at that
moment is absent is not there I'm just
dealing with the situation and it has
been shown in the university that our
stress levels the stress hormone levels
are able to be raised lying in bed more
than somebody in fear for the first time
going into a bunker jump oh goes but
other jump doing a bungee jump for the
first time yeah yeah but not me but
because a bunker jump you you are
attached but very unexpected situations
in in nature like a blizzard or swimming
beneath the ice and losing the whole
because your eyesight is gone things
like that or climbing without gear steep
mountains and having cramps and what do
you do at that moment and that that's
exactly what I learned how to raise
consciously the stress hormone level
purely controlled and I'm able to deal
with a situation at that moment without
panicking and I think that's one
the crucial findings which could benefit
for human mankind as it is you know very
subjected to stress all the time
panicking having fear and all that and I
learned in nature how to deal with that
and the cult brought me and brought me
that science brought me that knowledge
wisdom actually and the the raising of
stress from on so to controlling
something that has long been thought to
be part of the autonomous nervous system
something that you have no control over
right and we'll get to the breathing
because breathing is very interesting
since it's both autonomous but you can
you can consciously control it and
practice different methods I think it
was it was certainly in the vice
documentary that recently came out which
I recommend to everyone and I'll link to
in the show notes but was it in 2011
that you were injected with some type of
virus or bacteria - exactly you could
control the immune response that was at
the Dutch I'm going to mispronounce the
redwood University exactly wrap out the
University in Holland and the
intensive-care nuclear science I
underwent a an experiment and they
injected me with a endotoxin with a
toxin actually which is a part of a
bacteria and that creates a very
dramatic immune response and as we have
no control over the immune response in
our body they thought I was not able to
do it as well as expected because nobody
showed to be able to suppress the immune
response because it is part of the
autonomic nervous system and nobody is
able to do that until now I showed that
I was very able within a quarter of an
hour instead of hours suffering from
uncontrolled shivering fever headaches
and all that I show within a quarter of
an hour that you have control complete
over the symptoms and also decide to
cane
witches are which are the flam Ettore
beings in the blood created by the
immune response and I showed in the
blood and by blood results to suppress
them dramatically and within a quarter
and then they told me okay but you are
an exception that confirms the rule
because yeah yeah yeah you have been
training so many years you are the eyes
man you do exceptional features but
nobody is able to do that without that
proper training of so many years and I
told them no I can train them within 10
days and then the professor was really
chilled because if this group would show
to be able within ten days to be able to
influence deeply into the autonomic
nervous system related to the immune
system then that's for the first time in
the scientific history so but he he saw
the indication of the possibility but
still thought those guys are not going
to be able to do that
within 10 days you know what it wasn't
within ten days it wasn't with four days
of training that I made them able to
undergo the same experiment that that
means the injection of the endotoxin and
have them within a quarter of our
completely control over their immune
system related to the autonomic nervous
system so they showed a hundred percent
school of everybody to be able within a
couple of days to go air to tap into the
autonomic nervous system related to the
immune system
and yeah and the training about to
training be a prior to it and we had our
beers you know in the evening and there
a lot of music and very relaxed and and
there
mindset I said hey guys probably you you
guys are the new gladiators well we are
going to win
the worst war ever which produced a much
the most casualties agony pain and all
that and that's the bacteria that's the
back so that's the virus and we're gonna
win this war are you with me
I that's the way I talk to them and so
they had a mindset so in the evening we
had a relaxing hey it was like a hippie
movement but this is a new revolution
and in four days time they were able at
the fourth day without prior experience
in the cold they were able to go in
shorts at by minus ten
that's about I don't know in the
Fahrenheit Celsius this is salty that
means freezing cold yeah early in the
20s brilliant yes in the twenty below
freezing yeah and then for hours and
hours we were going up hill and up to
mountain and we arrived at the summit
after hours and it was minus 27 minus 27
Celsius that a dentist's more than - and
then 20s it's probably 10 something like
that and we danced the Harlem shake Oh
out there then I knew these guys these
guys are ready in four days time when
they will be internalized in the in the
hospital and injected with the endotoxin
they will be able because I feel when
somebody is back into its natural state
of his or hers physiology and I know how
to do that
the the cold trade me the cold is my
teacher and with it with these subjects
I'm so curious to ask because
the I mean I am certainly not as
proficient as you are in any of these
techniques but I've I've enjoyed
experimenting over the last 10 years in
writing about these short experiments
whether it's related to breath holding
with David Blaine or other aspects
obviously you're a professional and I am
NOT but I'm so I'd be a very curious to
hear you
perhaps elaborate for instance on the
first day of training with these
subjects but in preparation to be
injected four days later sure what did
the first day of training look like for
them and just in the morning at ease at
8 o'clock without food intake we do
breathing and they lie on the ground all
because that's the most relaxed pose and
if you are relaxed you're able to store
up almost a lot more oxygen than when in
tension or in post you so I say to man I
just lay down there relax now we are
going to begin just breathe in deeply
and let go breathe in deeply let go
make it a rhythm breathe and deeply let
go not fully out but fully in and let go
and we repeat that about 30 40 times
until these indications or symptoms come
by and that it means lightheadedness
loose in the body feeling loose in the
body tingling contractions
that's because carbon dioxide goes out
oxygen is roaming freely throughout the
body and the pH levels rise they are
optimized so they get to their best
condition and that's proven that's
proven and they saw a when we do this
and they so they saw all these results
chemically then once you feel positively
charged with all these symptoms of
lightheadedness feeling loose
contractions and tingling in the body
ask them just breathing deeply let go
and now the last time breathing deeply
let's go and after letting go after
exhalation stop we frame from breathing
there's no need we get a whole lot of
oxygen and measurement devices are not
able to detect how much it's more than
100 percent that's my opinion but device
still are not able to detect that they
only can go up to a hundred percent as
they say but there are other percent
that a body is able to store up more
oxygen than measurement devices of now
are able to measure so then after 1/2
minutes then you see that the
measurement device shows 100% and then
it goes dramatically down afterwards and
you're using a pulse oximeter like
something that you clip on your gather
yes polls exam so so you need a heart
beat you have a heart beat and you have
the saturation of the oxygen in inside
the blood so the amount of oxygen so
after 1/2 minutes you see with everybody
that the saturation of the blood is
going down you know people with COPD
that that's lung diseases and all that
they they suffer from real severe COPD
when they have 85 we go to 90 to 80 70
60 50 people died at 50 and 40 40
percent saturation in the blood we go
past we go even to 30 and then the
device measurement device the occu meter
shuts down it is not measuring anymore
but we even go past that one now why
don't you why
the subjects pass out at this point they
don't pass out and because they are
outlined I say they're the ph degrees
are really perfect at that moment and
instead of a person who's dying is very
acidic so that's the difference so
because we are so alkaline people maybe
sometimes are able to pass out but just
two seconds or three seconds because
they get they are out of their
conditioned control and but in a you
know after exercising they have every
regain not only control in those moments
and in those situations they they win a
new part in the brain they get in very
deep in the brain and it's all new
terrain it's like a baby a baby has no
problem with whatever relax but there
are no motoric matura chol neurons to
the legs yet ray zaps
so we are going into different parts of
the brain where there is where the guy
or the girl that has been right so it's
logic that the people are able to pass
out but nothing happens because they are
alkaline so they just wake up and mostly
all mostly almost always they wake up
very happy and it's like a drug
experience so but that's besides of the
real effect I'm trying to not not try
which we showed scientifically is to be
able to tap into the immune system in
all the layers those are three layers
and normally and we are not able to get
into the second and the third layer and
I say now we have found a key to the
second and third layer that means the
nonspecific immune system
and the specific adaptive immune system
and that makes us looking to disease
completely different because our ability
is so much more and we have been
publishing
people in Boston they published it
throughout America on the university's
chapter 22 on biology now and it tells
that we have tapped into the autonomic
nervous system into the in eight innate
immune system which was up till now not
possible and we did at hundred percent
with a group of nine people and showing
that they were very able to do it all
all of them within a quarter of an hour
and have spectacular results so it that
it is science now and now needs to get
to every person in the world how to tap
into the deeper layers of our physiology
without training you know years and
years and years and being Yogi's or
being a the super athletes and all that
no my aim is within a couple of days we
are all able to tap into the deepest
layers of our physiology and reset our
immune system you bring it under our
will and that's my aim but then we make
fun too and all that but for sale and
being serious that's my goal right no I
was just gonna say I mean it's very hard
to get the I think you're approaching it
in a very intelligent way because it's
very hard to get truly serious work done
if you're serious all the time so yeah I
enjoy it's very fascinating for me as a
teacher to watch how you coach your
subjects because you use beer you have
guitar and I think it's a very important
component it was you seem to be and I
wanted to ask you about the breathing on
day one just one more time which is yeah
is is the breathing exercise on day one
something that then the subjects use
during the injection or before the
injection or is it an exercise to prove
to them that they can do more than they
think they can do and it's more of a
confidence builder that you use to set
the tone for the rest of the training
yes both so it's a confidence builder
and is very effective at the moment when
something like an injection is come in
and they know it will result in dramatic
immune response and they have to build
up and make alert their shield or their
protective protective lines of defense
which is the immune system yes so both
whoa and is this something that you can
do after the fact so for instance at
this point with your your level of
proficiency if you were to contract a
disease without realizing it and then to
get very sick would you be able to
reverse that or is it something that
needs to be is that does the shield need
to be activated beforehand in order for
you to control that autonomous so called
autonomous response interesting very
nice it's both preventive and healing so
once a specific hormone or molecule must
be generated to get to a invader a
non-self invader in the body which could
be a bacteria a virus or a back cell
which got through the first two lines of
defense then the third line is more
specific but it takes normally like
weeks or sometimes it's not traceable
because I an invader is mutating but we
have now a method that is able to tap
into the third layer and make the nonce
the specific adaptive immune system
rapidly active even after something
comes in and so it's both preventive but
is also when you feel you become sick so
a an invader has gotten in then you are
still a very able to restore the balance
within goddess yes and the if we're
looking at the the explanation that the
scientists have at this point for your
ability and your subjects ability to
protect themselves or shield themselves
it seemed like one hypothesis was you
being able to increase I think
noradrenaline or norepinephrine levels
in the body do you agree with that or do
you think there are other do you have
other theories I do I do
I'd love to eat or not it's like if you
have HIV and then the immune system is
still looking for answers up till a
moment that it is not able to specify
anymore what's going on and then we get
AIDS and that that means that all the
defense systems are shut down now we
have shown by norepinephrine and no
adrenaline adrenaline and that we can
suppress the inflammation that means the
flama Tori bodies and creating an immune
response and we suppress it that would
be like shutting down the immune system
that makes us following the scientific
logic that makes us more vulnerable know
what we do and they still gotta find out
but I just use my natural logic and you
can read upon in the in the in the in
the papers and that we have found a way
to awaken the third line which normally
takes weeks or months to to
is specific hormone or molecule which
then is a going for the target cell to
go on the membrane and to kill the cell
so that's interesting it's it's it's
almost like internal drug development
you're trying to find the lock that I'm
sorry the key that fits the proper lock
but you're doing it internally yeah it
normally takes very long time
biologically - yep - to sort of a to
conclude with that you're accelerating
that process exactly and then days
hormones are not needed anymore because
the specific warmer the specific
molecule gets on the cell membrane and
then all this like fire people which is
snore adrenaline gets throughout the
system and the epinephrine as well and
they suppress the inflammation the the
action and but that is only possible
when the the target is already
annihilated when the target has a
specific molecule on it because of the
third line of defense right and that's
that that's what we found we found a way
at its altar dr. Kevin Tracy from
Manhasset New York who tells them he is
very much he's an authority in the
biochemistry and I worked with him in
2007 and I showed I was able in his
Institute to suppress or to influence
the fake nerve which is over the vagus
nerve yeah yes and now he told in nature
he told immunity does not come without
neuro regulation they found a way so
what you now for instance I was I did my
undergraduate for a very short period of
time in college I studied neuroscience
and I remember when I was in college
there was a professor there who
determined that for instance the
in the hippocampus could actually be
regenerated and this was very very big
big news because people had assumed for
a very long time in a number of parts of
the brain that neurons could not be
degenerated but are regenerated
basically as you got older you just lost
neuro neuronal function and it could not
be restored now we know that's not true
right and so you're having this similar
experience where you are proving to
people that things are possible that
we're thought impossible what what do
you think what other Impossibles do you
think we will prove are possible in the
next say five years in your kind of area
of experimentation very very nice
thought and a very good question and I
think a a depression for example and the
brains itself and we are able to tap
into the brains and do so much more
influence so much more and which is
related to the hypothalamus and the
pineal gland pituitary gland the
hippocampus and the amygdala the seed of
emotion all these are part and around
the brainstem which is the reptilian
brain the primitive brain and because of
our comfort way of living and behavior
this part doesn't get enough stimulation
right we are untrained yes that doesn't
get this stimulation nor oxygen so there
is a certain kind of deregulating pH
level we are going on it's just to add
lack of oil oxygen there is no action no
stimulation so in time it begins to
malfunction and that's a that's actually
a sort of a logic so we suffer from a
whole lot for example of depression in
the Western world because because we go
too much into the neocortex the the
superficial brain the new brain and we
have to do all kinds of things and that
deadlines and worries and we cannot
and it consumes all the energy what I do
and learn is to go into the brainstem
again they said the simplicity of our
reptilian brain the primitive brain the
brain stem which is related to all these
beautiful glance over there which is the
pineal gland pituitary gland and and a
controller of us which is the
hypothalamus right and the seed of
emotion itself which is the amygdala and
it's all there and so I found a way to
get into that and show just by this
example of ours
to lying and bet people are able to
produce more adrenaline than somebody
who is in fear going into a bumpy jump
for the first time you see what I mean
right
that that means fear emotion
uncontrollable emotions and fear we are
able to control them and that's because
we tap controlled into the brainstem and
produce any adrenaline or epinephrine or
all these all these gland no not dance
hormones we need and it's the pineal
gland in the finally which is the
control of all the other glands in our
body so we are able now to tap into that
so the coming five years I want to
eradicate a depression I want to really
eradicate the yeah actually a disease I
know there are big words but we are into
that I'm not only into that these are
also professors biochemists stamp my
point and they see it's so simple so
accessible and so effective but it needs
to be translated into our infrastructure
of thinking as well as of in
trysts it needs to cooperate with
schooling now we got on the University
that's nice it's coming top-down because
oh if the US universities are taking it
on then soon all the universities in the
world will follow so we find okay I rest
my point for for now and we are yeah so
with for instance depression so there
I'm sure there are a lot of people
listening who have bouts with depression
or even extended depression yes no
control over their mood right that's no
control over the brainstem right so
let's break it back to the brainstem
right so for instance you know I find
that it's very helpful for me at least
to use cold exposure and whether that's
cold showers or ice baths it has a
tremendous mood elevating effect or
maybe mood exactly a balancing effect
depending on on how we want to explain
it but for someone who is feeling
depressed what are some simple things
that you would recommend that they try
potentially first get into conscious
breathing deeper breathing and be
consciously doing that it showed in the
university that I was able just you know
about consciousness just by thinking
that I was going into an experiment I
raised cell on cell level the metabolic
activity in the cell were 300 percent
just by thinking that our mind so our
mind should be with people who are
depressed they just got lost they have
no control so they have to regain
control by consciously going into
breathing breathing brings about deeper
breathing but brings about a better pH
level in the body but not only in the
body also in the mind and the right pH
level will
the neurotransmitters that's your mind
the electrical signals finally work
better and that you are able to learn to
direct these neurotransmitters or
thoughts the mind itself consciously
with a right pH degree so we make it
simple and we say conscious breathing
all the time because you lost track and
it takes energy takes your mind and it
you've got to bring back your mind under
your control and I mean this I think is
related to a broader topic of compulsive
behavior right or people who have
automatic behaviors that are not serving
them and one of those is oftentimes
eating or overeating and before we
started recording and I asked you what
you had for breakfast and he said
nothing because you eat once per day so
I could you describe what your daily
eating ritual is I eat after 6 o'clock
in the afternoon and that's already for
35 years and there is I got a lot of
energy and you know why you're a lot of
allergies no energy
oh I'm sorry sorry got it baby allergies
as well women you know okay it just made
fun yeah yeah and I think you and I have
to have wine next time we do this thing
is very healthy very good and the thing
is by better breathing conscious
breathing you made this chemical process
in the in the cell happen which is
called aerobic dissimulation and as you
know in the cell production to make
energy mitochondrial energy you need
food but if you are able to influence by
better breathing a deeper breathing then
you produce simple metabolic activity in
the mitochondria
by better breathing and that creates
energy which was the purpose of food so
food is nice
hello I'm here oh oh yeah food is nice
food is great you should do it with a
lot of love and they're having a nice
time making it and they're because
that's the energy you get finally ultra
but a and like me if I like it's a sort
of a fast but I have to feel your ear
the sentence really gets our going to be
much more effective and the cell
activity is going to be much more
effective and it is using all the food
and you can eat after six o'clock I can
eat what I want the other day I'm slim
again and that's making you know making
the body work but as we eat all the day
long the body is not shutting down it's
not effective anymore doesn't go deep
doesn't go into survival motors it's not
natural again so it's beginning to store
up all the fats because it doesn't know
what to do anymore because the deeper
mechanisms are not working anymore
so yeah and we're going to bring that
and what do you usually what it what are
some typical meals that you have after
6:00 p.m. but uh I like pasta and I like
a couple of beers to Panda yeah sounds
good I the eating rituals very
interesting I've interviewed a number of
people on this podcast including General
Stanley McChrystal as a four-star
general and he was he's also famous for
getting a lot of exercise early in the
day and eating one meal per day he's
also he's also very well known for that
you you described the breathing exercise
some of the breathing exercises that you
do it does the type of breathing that
you do have anything ease is it similar
in any ways to holotropic breathwork if
you're familiar with that
and I heard from someone and maybe you
can correct me if I'm wrong that some
scientists had looked at at whether you
were producing or releasing more DMT
during some of your breathing activities
is that accurate or that did I get some
misinformation from someone just be very
know that's a professor right yeah I
don't know a calibrate oh I don't know
where what is his name again I don't
know he's a authority in the field but I
had a dialogue with him and he is
talking about all these you know
ayahuasca and all those drugs and all
this and experimenting and I said I told
him I'm able to produce to trigger the
pineal gland in a way that DMT is
released and and yes I can make people
very very happy doing all these
breathing exercises that that's true but
the purpose of DMT actually is to work
out the subconscious while dreaming in
the rapid eye movement sleep and the
other one is when you die then DMT is
released as well as to make it more an
hour happy grown after and having a have
a have a nice time go to the other side
something like that so there is a
natural purpose for DMT but we are we
are very I'm very able to trigger that
that creates DMT and I told him and I
told him alter it's not only about the
DMT which is very nice it's a nice drug
and all that but the better part of it
is if we are able to to trigger the
pineal gland which is related directly
to the hypothalamus and the pituitary
gland if we are able to trigger that one
and to decalcify because of our comfort
way of living the this anil gland then
the
gland is able to to direct all the other
glands it's the only gland that is
directing all the other glands and we
can bring we can narrowly connect with
it without our neocortex is what we do
and it shows them that we are able to
prevent from disease or bacteria coming
because we are able to activate it
much more directly and and that's the
main purpose to you know for looking
different at what the creates disease
it's because of our pineal gland or the
brain stem is not really active anymore
because it's neglected because of a
conflict style of living and behavior
and we want to make a shortcut and to
showed that it is simple accessible
ineffective well I think that the unity
the comfort is important to underscore
because I was having a conversation with
Dean Karnazes several years ago he's a
famous ultra marathoner you guys would
probably have a lot to talk about and he
ran near 50 marathons in 50 days and 50
states he's one of those guys and he
said that he lives in Northern
California near San Francisco where I
live and he's in one of his lines and I
might be paraphrasing this but he said
you know people now they confuse being
happy with being comfortable they think
being comfortable is being happy but
that those are not the same thing
and I'd like to talk about discomfort
for a second so you ran a marathon in
was it Death Valley with no water yes I
think like that yeah and that may be a
not Namibia that's right
even so you even more dangerous because
you have snakes and whatnot so is it
possible to not so of course when you
are submerged in ice it's been
demonstrated that you can maintain your
core body temperature for a very long
period of time is it possible for you to
drop your body temperature in a hot
climate or if you just is it training
yourself to withstand the higher
temperature
yes exactly both actually
your tolerance is rising and that means
you are able to endure a whole lot more
because you are able to influence their
hormonal system in a way that
neutralizes pain signals that's one the
other one is because of my training in
the cold I not only trained in the cold
I trained to end or impact of
temperature and those are receptors of
ours which I have trade and then because
of that which is part which is
controlled by the hypothalamus is the
thermal regulator of our body and
because I trained in the cold I trained
the thermal regulation of the body then
without training without training a
meter of running and then not drinking a
full marathon in the Namib Desert in the
heat without prior training or ever been
there before and I was very able to do
that because this thermal regulative
mechanism the hypothalamus I had trained
in a in the cold which is the
temperature impact so I learned to deal
with the temperature and you know what
and not only the temperature which is
cold and heat but also deprivation of
oxygen that means going up now Mount
Everest in short and that means it was a
very cold out there there is no oxygen
and you need oxygen to for combustion in
the in the cell to create heat energy
and there is no oxygen so I learned in
the cold how to deal with impact on the
bed nervous system on our metabolism
that means cold deprivation of oxygen a
heat but also stress daily stress so
the secret of our comfort as you say and
the people say they are confusing like
the paraphrasing this this this great
guy of Northern California who is
telling the truth we are confused we
don't know anymore what real comfort is
real comfort is the power to regulate
all the impacts existent in in life
that means disease which is impact on
our body a heat cold deprivation of
oxygen stress in general any stress and
we are able to control that a whole lot
more and that brings about the real
comfort because if you connect yourself
with all these older systems within then
you feel really good real good
is real connection and that that that's
something be a going B that's why all
these outdoor freaks and the idiots and
a titre like myself are doing this
because we just feel good well it seems
like it's also a feeling comfort is in a
way becoming confident in discomfort
right so you you have a confidence that
you can handle and adapt to whatever's
going to come your way much like some of
the I suppose you know elite military
that I've met who are very actually very
relaxed I mean the most most of the high
level guys I've met because they have
systematically exposed themselves to
discomfort so they don't fear discomfort
if that makes sense
exactly they control their stress
hormone release completely right that's
what I'm talking about now you you speak
how many languages do you speak
10 10 that is a lot of languages how did
you learn that many languages just be
open and love to learn and that's it I
had no real teachers then you know
people in the street then sometimes I
had to look for a teacher like a
Japanese teacher we're here in Amsterdam
and the hindu teacher pundit and so yeah
i was just interested if you are
interested in life you get to know and
you never stop learning because you love
it its young is what language of all the
languages you've tried what was the
hardest for you the horrors maybe polish
polish because it's a complete different
set of grammatical structures i say
polish in nostrovia I bet you know that
one yeah yes we definitely have to have
a round two with some with some wine and
beer but the the next question I'd love
to ask is perhaps a simple one but why
are people fat and how can people
develop more brown fat and use it
effectively yes people are being fat
because it's a protective mechanism ulta
over our bodies
it's actually an answer to do on too
much impact too much wrong chemistry
going on so it wants to make an
insulation that's a that's a natural
thing to do of the body now we are
suffering from that now it's called
obesity and being overweight we have no
control just bring them back to the
control how do we do that by by this
adipose brown fat adipose because and
they have a mostly of those people have
also in absence of brown fat because
they have no stimulation anymore for
longer time and then this insulation
reflex is beginning to build up and
build up but actually this is telling a
guy I'm trying to do my best for you but
you are not doing anything in return and
as long as you're not triggering or
stimulating the adipose the brown fat
then it succumbs it goes away
and and and then it is not able to to to
divert to white fat into energy anymore
right so it's gone with people with the
obesity they have no brown fat anymore
so there is a logic explanation to it
now I know it so they have to bring it
back and is that cold exposure primarily
there would be the first step to try to
hold cold exposure not a natural
exposure to the elements that's one in
an adaptive way gradual way I mean then
we are able to adapt to with it but as
these mechanisms are not working really
well within these people so they have to
be very you know a sensitive and and and
gradual going into it and breathing
breathing is chemistry's chemica is
influencing the chemistry right here
right now better breathing deeper
breathing brings about a better ph
degree in the body which then finally
results in the faster metabolism and if
people are practicing this or want to
pack practices breathing on their own is
there any particular mantra or anything
they should focus on or say to
themselves as they're doing this is any
type of meditation okay to start with
like using an app like headspace or calm
or do you have a particular
recommendation if someone said I have 10
minutes a day I'm willing to spend doing
this what would you say to them yeah
just have you favorite music going on go
really into it and go really into the
breathing because it's about chemical
changes and whenever you hear the right
music you are able to relax more and
more oxygen than is able to get into the
body which is finally changing the pH
levels in the body to the to its natural
state that's what we have a because we
live in such a you know compressed
society are too much stress going on we
do not have control of the stress
we get out of our natural state so
within ten minutes we are I say within
four minutes just do this breathing
exercise which I teach people and do
push-ups push-ups without air in the
lungs you should do that so you do that
after the after the exhale yes
after yeah first you do like thirty like
I explained deeply with it let go deeply
within a look at the indications of
feeling loose in the body and light had
it you know contractions a little bit
tingling that's all okay like thirty or
forty deep breaths and then letting go
forty times then you will arrive at that
being charged with oxygen and the co2
carbon dioxide got away pH level has
gotten up then you shoot breathing fully
letting go after exhalation you stop and
you go do push-ups and you will see you
are able to do more push-ups without air
in the lungs because you influence into
the chemistry hmm that's and probably a
good idea to do in a soft surface first
just in case you decided to kiss the
floor a little too hard now this is
something that that Laird and his guys
have been working on as well I mean a
lot of these guys are working and doing
push-ups or stationary bike very
interesting they have free divers that
sometimes work out with it's very
fascinating great well I'm going to try
that I would love to switch gears just a
little bit and ask you a couple of rapid
questions you can certainly take your
time it doesn't mean you have to answer
them quickly but the the first is when
you think of the word successful who is
the first person who comes to mind for
you
the heart and any person the heart the
heart in any person hmm
that that's success yeah and the fact
that whether maybe Mandela Nelson
Mandela yes and in with the heart if
someone feels like if someone doesn't
you're successful what would you what
would your advice be to them or what
would you what would you say to them
yeah just do the method I mean this
method is showing scientifically to be
able to tap into the deepest of our
physiology if somebody feels he's
frustrated it's because he is not able
to tap in his or hers physiology at the
deepest he has no control that makes
people frustrated and we we we mirror
that with society and all that but you
got your vehicle if you are able to
steer your vehicle your body your mind
to work or whatever you feel then you
will be successful and any front yes
I'm sorry interrupt I was just gonna ask
why Nelson Mandela
oh yeah he's just a good guy was always
smiling he loved the women and he stayed
like 25 years believing in this case
right and that makes him for me really
strong and I love people who have faith
simply because that's what I feel
and yes I I've been in so many years
neglected and mocked mocked and all that
but I always had my faith and now it is
science for the same like 20 years ago
they told me you're crazy you're an
idiot
you're a lunatic and all that yes and
even my in my family I was the black
sheep and right now I'm the wider sheep
ever so it's a lot of hypocrisy going on
in the world because people do not know
but I got my faith I got my belief and I
want to go up to the point that we
scientifically showed everybody is able
to tap in it's a endocrine system and so
much that depression and being unhappy
and being frustrated is no longer part
of humanity it's a choice
no this is a this is a topic I think we
could talk about for a long time what is
your favorite book or the book that
you've given to other people the most as
a gift
whoa never gave so many books except for
the books hop right right haha
what do you give to people as gifts what
do you like my give people as gifts Oh
as stones stones a lot of certain
natural things I get people natural
things
oh I collect a whole bunch of things and
then two months later I'm I'm fed up
with the thing and then I think this one
wants to go with you hahaha and those
are beautiful stones when I told them
the first time I thought wow great stone
beautiful oh this artifact
well what grade Wow nice then two months
later until it's gone yeah then I just
gave it away and so and what works the
same thing and as Siddhartha Siddhartha
and Jonathan Livingston Seagull comes to
my mind and that's okay in some
scriptures I read about the
bhagavad-gita and the Bible of course
obey all these books and I was reading
hundreds of books and at a certain point
I could not make connection with my the
deepest within myself which was the
seeker I was soul searching and I found
it finally in the open book of the ice
water because the ice water is merciless
but righteous it brings you just within
and there is no there is no
chit-chatting around that there is no
philosophy you just do it right or you
do it wrong now you've had of course
some some very challenging times perhaps
more so than many people I've spoken
with you had very you know tragic
premature death with your wife in the
case your wife
what do you do to to overcome those dark
periods yes very very good
very interesting very real indeed good
losing the person you love I have four
children with her they work with me
right now
they are like 33 years old her oldest
one and then two daughters and another
son and they all work with me right now
Oh actually one is working right now at
the Dutch embassy in Washington DC in
America but the rest is working with me
all the time so and losing the love of
your life how deep can you go and being
Ted apart that was what I was
experienced at the time but then I was
the only person who was real I was alone
and I had to raise four kids alone and
that they were like seven years they are
old eight years nine years and eleven
years and I had to raise them alone so I
received so much love of my kids and I
did my training and as I told you the
the brain stem is it all to the area of
the seed of emotion which is the
amygdala and because of this training in
the cold I could control silenced myself
and go on and always find the energy to
go on and to be a father happy and
exercising and practical and with my
kids and they gave me a lot of love but
the thing about grief and the emotion is
you have to go deep because emotion is
going deep and as we live in the comfort
zone we have no control mostly over
emotion and I tell you there is a way to
control the seat of
motion which is the amygdala connected
to the in the area of the brainstem
so I think this a not think my
experience tells me discipline
discipline and believing believing
within there is a wait to silence a
grieved broken hearts grief and pain and
hurt emotions yes its own it's the way I
did it and the its it's really been
fascinating for me to observe a number
of people I won't mention some of the
other names but who have used
specifically exposure to the cold to I
suppose the purity of that cold and the
attention that requires a sort of purity
of attention that it requires to
overcome very dark periods or be it to
act as a very strong component for
passing through those difficult periods
it's just it's a very fascinating
pattern that I've observed in a number
of my number of my friends I recognize
him what is what is your morning the
first 60 minutes of your day look like
when do you wake up what do you do in
those four sixty minutes if you have
complete control over that morning first
time get to conscious breathing we're
consciously breathe when you wake up yes
and your life is all about vital force
created by oxygen just it's for free and
it's there and I say it's to me it's
okay it's God itself they like Ponemah
the vital for inochi the prana it's all
a different names of God and they tell
all the the belief systems tell that
that's the vital force of any yeah of of
life itself so that's the that's a very
logic natural way I begin to us breathe
still lay still laying in bed yes
they're laying in bed and then doing the
exercise which I explained prior
this interview is yeah it is it is very
nice because you are still very relaxed
and about the body is without tension so
you then are able to go tap deeply into
the system and how long will you do that
in bed typically yes a first a 1/2 hour
something like that before I'm going
into action could be an hour because
it's never never boring what would you
say to someone who says you know
actually I find it really boring I'm not
saying that I feel that way but if I got
if someone felt boring what would you
what would you advise them or what would
you tell them it's it once again the
same thing as this Californian the great
guy Dido at Internet yeah being Knesset
and they don't know what comfort is all
about so a go indeed just by breathing
into the depth of our physiology
it's like gaining the aim of all those
people going into outdoor or taking
drugs or a doing extremes or go for a
rush now you can are abled to learn to
control the depth of your physiology by
just breathing properly and going into
that system and boring is something if
you are doing things repetitiously but
not breaking through the conditioning
right now i learned people to go through
the conditioning right so if you have to
be conscious about the activity you
can't be daydreaming well it seems you
just have to be attentive to your
breathing when you're doing something
like this yes yes just go into it it's
like the partner meditation that's what
I do you know if they sit and they just
listen and and focus on breathing that's
all what I do and they get into a deeper
layer of their brain because they are
not giving their focus to something else
than just Maher
breathing it is so simple but so
effective I'll try that tomorrow morning
the so let's say you do that for a half
hour then what do you do for the next
half hour uh nowadays I do a lot too I'm
doing a lot of workshops lectures and
I'm into science but yeah for in-between
I do exercising
I like exercising what type of exercise
do you if you had to choose one type of
exercise or two types of exercise for
yourself what would you choose strength
and flexibility what would you do for
both of those a strength for example
stay on two arms say four minutes like a
planet or just different types of poses
on to our yeah with one anti or to a
plank or handstands or pull-ups push-ups
of course and those are you know power
exercises or stand in the world stands
for an hour that is sometimes they just
do with stones in my hands and make all
kinds of kung-fu like movements just
make them up and but you know do better
my acidic the acidic processes in my
body so I go deeply into the horse
stance and breathe in a way that a asset
is not developing in the body so that
makes me control the body and that feels
good and then for flexibility yeah all
kinds of splits and then put a couple of
legs amaya
behind my head thinks you know where do
balancing exercises it's nice sir III
maintain the body that way what do you
listen to music when you're exercising
or do you do it without music alright I
simply have no record system so but a in
right now I'm
we bought a center so I will have my big
dojo and well a cascade and all that and
a swimming pool and all those things and
that I will have the right music and
make music myself I play the guitar I
say I want to make a CD very soon and
people like me singing doing all kinds
of mantras because I you know learnt
about the sunscreen and and a Spanish
song to English songs and all kinds of
songs I just make up I'm a sort of a
rapper too so yeah I'd love to hear it
and what what musician do you look up to
the most is there a particular musician
that you admire that you would like to
emulate or look up to like a lot a lot a
lot of lounge easy music I like Michael
Jackson Michael Jackson's great yeah
yeah he is stupid you have a favorite
song or a favorite album of Michael
Jackson yes yeah all the songs this is
it for example to gorilla oh yeah great
deal is great
and his voice is mesmeric oh yeah
totally
yes so I I gave my son his name which is
Michael which is one of my songs so
things like that but also Pink Floyd
also Gypsy Kings you know there's a big
you know flamenco and all the good music
there's a lot of good music going on and
there yes I can't wait to visit the the
center is that going to be in Holland
yes okay for now it's in Holland I was
looking to make a centre in the near San
Francisco as well I got some very good
friends over there you should you should
you should come out maybe we'll do a
workshop and I can introduce you to I'll
invite Dean as well you could meet Dean
yes yes he's a great guy he's a great
guy
you would look he would love to meet you
I'm sure the just a few more questions I
want to be obviously respectful of your
time
what what purchase in the last you know
six months or a year of less than $100
so something you bought for less than
$100 as most positively impacted your
life it stones stones
I love these stones I want to talk about
so how do you find these stones and what
makes you pick one do you have any
favorites I always take a stones out
whatever touches my meats di I take them
from the mountainside client but I also
like these you know amethyst sand
Oh pails and all kinds of you know
beautiful stones with the beautiful
colors I like them but yeah I always
take stones from the I just found a big
fossil in the in disparaged Pyrenees
you know big big means like two to three
kilos Elsa B has a big big fossil there
yeah foster and and I couldn't get it
down because I was there with a group at
the ad nowhere backpack I had to carry
the the ropes because we were doing
Canyon right all that so but there was a
girl from Austin Texas Austin Elizabeth
Lee and she had a backpack and he she
carried it there for me it's a good
friend yeah oh she I love it so much
yeah so the what what effect do and did
you do put that in your kitchen where do
you put such a such a stone and what
effect does it have on you everywhere
they they have a solid effect say simply
there and they are beautiful and I
always pass them on to other people
except for the big ones
Hulse it what what advice would you give
your 30 year old self my 30 and Jeff I
faith just have faith faith yes but then
that what what type of faith that things
will work out the things will be okay
say is simple logic have sinned
the logic and understand the things
simply and listen to your feeling hmm
listen to your feeling you're feeling it
knows is it is simply sense making and
that if you are letting it in your way
of thinking then never lose track of
whatever makes sense which is feeling
which is instinct and intuition right
right this is something I've been trying
to work on a lot because it's easy for
me at least to get trapped in my
neocortex to get trapped exactly in the
front of my brain where I can make pro
and con lists but the answer is so
obvious sometimes because you know that
something's wrong or you know that
someone isn't a good fit or you don't
trust someone just like you have that
feeling like a dog where you immediately
act like or dislike something
yes it's I've been trying to train
myself to go back to that simplicity
it's making sense it can be challenging
yeah the suit what one or two more
questions the if you could have one
billboard one huge sign anywhere with
anything on it what would it say and
where would you put it I would say
breathe [ __ ] so you could put
that on like a busy highway put that on
like Sunset Boulevard in Los Angeles or
yeah maybe yeah breathe I'm you know I
don't know why the way they understand
it but it's really meant loveable right
and you know which strength it is the
answer to D up till the DNA itself and
it's not me telling that anymore because
of the blood results professors have
confirmed that we are in the middle of
DNA and what is the trigger breathing so
this is a so you could you could have it
say
breathe breathe [ __ ] within a
smiley a smiley face like a smiley
emoticon that'd be perfect yeah so we
got a t-shirt it says on the front
please
you know it's about the cold and that
the other side is read [ __ ] well
you and I need to hang out more
I this has been great of course
everybody listening I'm going to put
tons of links in the show notes you
should check out Ice Man wim HOF wim HOF
definitely check out wim HOF method and
I'll link to that in the show notes
which is a 10-week online video course
which a bunch of people whose names you
would know are using right now it's very
very interesting and they're a bunch of
documentaries and links to the textbooks
I will include as well women do you have
any last requests or asks of my audience
there are a lot of people who will be
hearing this if you could ask them all
to do something besides check out the
courses and so on what would you ask
them to do something they could do when
they hear this or after they hear it
yeah just pass on a breathe that's one
and take a cold shower after a a hot
word and it just get into the signs of
this all it is non speculative and for
the rest I just love you guys
well when this is wonderful everybody
listening I will link to all these
things you can find wim on Twitter at
Iceman underscore HOF HOF and I'll link
to that Instagram same Iceman underscore
HOF facebook is facebook.com/paes man
and women thank you so much for taking
the time this was a blast
thank you very much I hear a soul mate I
thank you very much I love you very much
greetings to Ray Cronus definitely talk
to him B I will mail him also he loves
you and he loves your work he loves my
work you know we like to work to make
love happen definitely well we will
we'll play some guitar and have some
wine and you can oh yeah I would like I
would love to get into some shorts and
and freeze my ass off and breathe at
some point I know up
right up in the mountains I would be
they'll be great so uh until next time
thank you everybody for listening and
whim
thanks so much great thank you very much
- hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it this episode
is brought to you by a new sponsor so
listen up folks this is a good one
because have you ever wanted to be as
powerful as a mullet wearing ninja from
1980s movie or as flamboyant as big gay
al Big Al in South Park or as sleek as a
black panther in the Amazon on the hunt
well there's great news because I've
been testing this product that you wrap
around your genitals and it makes you
feel like a superhero and it is called
biondi's I've spent the last two to
three weeks traveling with underwear
from these guys and they are comfy I got
to tell you it feels like a Geisha is
giving your groin a hug and it's not
just for dudes but if you go to meet
undies com forward slash Tim that's meu
n di es com forward slash Tim you can
see all of the underwear that I've been
wearing there's some pretty ridiculous
ones and
I will also highlight my favorite you'll
probably be able to guess which it is
these are the rare made from micro model
which is extruded from Austrian
beechwood trees in the Alps
yes fancy and it's two times softer than
cotton scientifically tested using the
kalibata method developed in Kyoto
you know those Japanese very crafty and
I will say a few things number one if
you go to me on DS comm forward-slash
Tim you get to see all of these
spectacular underwear that I've been
wearing and I am a bit of an underwear
connoisseur socks fashion sense with
sweatpants not so much underwear I
understand so check them out and if you
go to Mandy's come forward slash Tim you
will also be able to see lots of hot
ladies wearing at me undies female
underwear and that's just a lot of
goodness for both the men and the women
out there so check it out me undies
dot-com forward slash Tim I love these
underwear and I'm going to be packing
tonight probably six to twelve pair to
take with me to Australia they're great
check them out me undies comm forward
slash Tim this episode is brought to you
by audible which I've used for years
I love audiobooks and I have to to
recommend right off the bat number one
is perhaps my favorite audio book of all
time and that is the graveyard book by
Neil Gaiman the only audiobook I've
wanted to immediately listen to a second
time as soon as I finished it's amazing
you will thank me to the graveyard book
the second is vagabonding by Rolf Potts
which had a huge impact on my life and
formed the basis for a lot of what
became the 4-hour workweek so all you
need to do to get your free audiobook
and a free 30-day trial is go to
audible.com forward slash Tim and you
can choose one of those two books the
graveyard book vagabonding or more than
180,000 audio programs so that could be
a book that could be a magazine that can
be a newspaper it could be a class it's
that easy go to audible.com forward
slash Tim that's audible.com
forward slash Tim and grab a book enjoy
if you want more of the tim ferriss show
you can subscribe to the podcast on
itunes
or go to for our blog calm fo you are
hou r BL OG calm where you'll find an
award-winning blog tons of audio and
video interview stories with people like
Warren Buffett and Mike Shinoda from
Lincoln Park the books plus much much
more follow Tim on twitter at
twitter.com/dspacestv our Riss or on
facebook at facebook.com slash Tim
Ferriss until next time thanks for
listening